[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 litres d'eau ensemble nous
allons faire le tour de l'actualité de
la semaine dans les yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 5 juin depuis
2019 le centre baroque de versailles
même des projets culturels
intergénérationnel et interculturel
cette année il proposait de travailler
autour de la fontaine avec des habitants
de trappes et la verrière nous verrons
comment ils se sont adaptés à la crise
sanitaire avec le coronavirus les
hôpitaux sous demande de la rs se sont
totalement réorganisé pour accueillir
les patients les opérations des
programmes et reprennent petit à petit
nous serons le coup avec l'hôpital privé
de versailles réouverture des terrasses
des bars et restaurants le retour au
collège pour certains élèves et les
listes du second tour officiellement
déposé nous reviendrons sur ce qui a
marqué le département cette semaine mais
avant ce dimanche 7 juin nous
célèbrerons les mamans et comme chaque
année le célèbre bouquet de fleurs sera
de rigueur pour cette fête
la boutique fleurs et passion située à
elancourt a rouvert le 14 mai et se
prépare à accueillir la clientèle en
magasin tout en respectant les gestes
barrières pour ce week-end lui si la
fleuriste prévoit plus de 200 commandes
les roses et les pivoines feront partie
des bouquets cette année mathilde 2010
la fête des mères c'est la plus grosse
est que ça soit en chiffres en
préparation en tant que préparation en
organisation en achat c'est la plus
grosse fête
nous on a laissé un petit peu les gens
choisir c'est à dire que s'ils sentent
en sécurité avec voilà un mas des gants
et cetera
m s'ils préfèrent l'enlever l'enlève
nous on se met juste en position d'être
éloigné voilà de vraiment de s'éloigner
de la personne ne pas être collée à la
personne pour que voilà qui la
distanciation
mais sinon rien de plus on a mis les
scotchs sol pour que les personnes se
rendent compte de la distance qu'il faut
on a mis du gel hydroalcoolique à la
caisse et surtout permettre aux
habitants de trappes et de la verrière
de découvrir l'univers de la fontaine
c'est le projet mené depuis 2019 par le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
lafontaine en scène est un projet
interculturel et intergénérationnel avec
la crise sanitaire il a dû se réinventer
explication dans ce reportage de aurélie
rose dans mon corps
il célèbre fable de la fontaine
réinterprétée par une artiste du centre
de musique baroque de versailles c'est
l'essence même du projet la fontaine en
scène lancé en octobre 2019 à la
verrière au programme pour les habitants
vers hyérois et trappistes deux ans
d'ateliers de rencontres artistiques
autour de la redécouverte des célèbres
fables mais le confinement a mis un coup
d'arrêt à la cinquantaine d'ateliers
pratiques prévu entre mars et mai pour
maintenir le lien entre les stagiaires
de l'école de la deuxième chance attrapé
l'univers de la fontaine le projet a dû
se réinventer le rat de vue l'europe des
chevaux autrefois le rat des villes
invite alors à deschamps d'une façon
fort civile à des reliefs d'ortho là les
artistes ont créé toute une vidéo
incitant les jeunes à se mettre en scène
en leur donnant des exercices très très
créatif
aussi durant le confinement l'équipe
artistique de la fontaine en scène a
posté une dizaine de vidéos elle à la
criée palier c'est la fournissent à vrai
dire la priant de décréter quelques
grains poursuivi cité jusqu'à la saison
pour l'instant les ateliers les
rencontres ne peuvent toujours pas
reprendre mais le cmbv à quelques pistes
pour que le projet puisse se poursuivre
qu'on a proposé à l'école des hemmes
chance de mettre à disposition certains
de nos locaux 102 personnes qui permet
de faire des tout petits groupes se
respecter la distance à la sensation
physique et ensuite bien sûr on se
projette en septembre en espérant alors
un rythme hebdomadaire
ce qui est souhaité
la vidéo va continuer à être largement
utilisé comme outil
le projet doit prendre fin en 2021 année
où l'on fêtera le 400e anniversaire de
la naissance de la fontaine le
coronavirus toujours en baisse dans les
yvelines au dernier décompte du jeudi 4
juin on comptait aucun nouveau patient
en réanimation sur les dernières 24
heures et 16 hospitalisation de moins
à noter tout de même un nouveau décès
menant à 480 18 le nombre total de morts
ducobu 19 à l'hôpital depuis le début de
la crise
[Musique]
avec la crise épidémique l' agence
régionale de santé a demandé aux
hôpitaux de reporter les interventions
non urgentes et limiter les activités de
soins pour pouvoir se concentrer sur les
passions dicko vide
la pandémie est en recul les activités
hospitalières reviennent petit à petit à
la normale c'est ce que nous allons
aborder avec eric luz directeur de
l'hôpital privé de versailles bonjour
bonjour m alors tout d'abord comment ça
s'est passé pour vous cette période si
particulière au sein de votre
établissement
il avait 10 h de titres nous avons donc
activer nos par milan blanc le 7 mars le
dernier et dans la foulée c'est à dire
dès le 13 mars des programmes et toutes
nos interventions chirurgicales en
urgence dabi tous les patients
nécessiteront pas de passer au bloc
opératoire dans le cadre via le service
des urgences
les patients effectivement le bonheur
pas de risque de perte de chance de voir
leurs interventions chirurgicales
reporter ou encore les patients atteints
d'un cancer et donc nous avons
transformé à l'intégralité de l'hôpital
privé de versailles dans 6 2 pour
accueillir je viens du tour la vague que
nous avons tous vécu d'être en capacité
d'accueillir des patientes and co guide
ce que nous avons créé puisque nous
avons transformé notre salle de réveil
en réanimation
quelle belle capacité dix patients
beaucoup plus haut de la vague nous
avons eu sept patients en simultané au
sein du service de réanimation au
bizouard il ya également les
d'hospitalisation de médecine comme
guide qui effectivement a été
opérationnel pendant deux mois avec bien
évidemment sa vie d'urgence qui est lui
aussi se garder nous est venue
finalement comme il ya deux services
créé en parallèle à la pointe pour les
passes effectivement si l'on convient de
rien et qui ment
pour les patients comme il est carrément
impossible d'aller pour charge dans le
milieu policier
quelle est la session aujourd'hui
comment préparez-vous l'art et
l'introduction des patients non qu'ovide
alors que timo glock comme on tient les
médias le relais depuis plusieurs
semaines un des milieux elle s'est
considérablement contractée au genou
parle le patient coville ou c'est un
établissement qu'il nous sommes
restructurés au pouvoir modestement
reprogrammer les patients effectivement
que nous avions des premiers depuis
mi-mars ce dernier avait effectivement
une nécessité d'être très vigilants le
sur des parcours de prise en charge avec
deux parcours qui sont identifiés à la
fois pour les patients qui sont les
boutiques les coquilles de lui tous les
essais avaient tous des prix en charge
chirurgicale ans et notre établissement
les autres patients qui les dons que
nous avons aujourd'hui au sein des blocs
opératoires ont services dédiés en
charge des patients mais aussi co lead
ils comptent effectivement sur nos
services d'hospitalisation avec un
questionnaire à la fois l'entrée pour
les patients - comment s'assurer una des
prélèvements doivent être prescrits par
les médecins qu'ils ne sont pas porteurs
effectivement du mobile mais aussi un
questionnaire à l'ensemble des
chirurgiens pouvoir motiver leurs
indications chirurgicales
autrement dit sur une analyse
bénéfices/risques consiste à qu'il a
confirmé l'intérêt de charge le patient
maintenant blocs opératoires il faut que
dans quelques semaines avec une
validation un vilain confirmait que le
patient vote des lois bien clan charge
chez nous
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça rassure les
patientes ça parce qu'on observe des
fois des personnes dont la maladie
peuvent s'aggraver parce qu'ils n'osent
plus aller à l'hôpital ou chez un
médecin tout simplement côtés de
plusieurs semaines voire même depuis le
début de l'épidémie que les patients
doivent continuer activement à venir au
sein de nos services urgences il exprime
bâtiment ou une nécessité de lumière
tous les médecins aussi développer la
téléconsultation qui permet semblé
accepter timents la ville ou d'un
généraliste inciter les patients à
consulter
physiquement ou à distance un médecin
les patients dont les opérations peut
être déprogrammée puis reprogrammé est
ce que le lien était maintenue comment
ça pas été trop difficile de leur
expliquer ça les médias en formation il
à libération
certains patients dont finalement rester
chez eux plutôt que de venir
effectivement cependant charge sur les
interventions non urgentes
en pleine crise ça libère des petits
paquets du ciel le différend nous avons
tous vêtus et le dia toujours des petits
malins nul entre le praticien qui le
patient alors je voulais aborder avec
vous la thématique de l'accouchement
on a vu émerger pas mal de témoignages
de jeunes mamans pour qui ça a été
difficile de se retrouver seul comment
on fait pour les accompagner ces femmes
la danse qui périodes comme celle-ci il
a été difficile pour nous d'un vernis
respectivement toutes les visites très
rapidement au début de la crise un
salutaire que les papas ou assister à
l'accouchement et donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui plaît
des patientes et depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant les bas par la
possibilité de rendre visite à leur
femme et à l'enfant cela effectivement
tous les jours avec évidemment des
contraintes d'hygiène
il est papa depuis trois semaines
l'hôpital de complètement se réorganiser
aujourd'hui on est on est ce qu'on va
vers une voie où on revient un peu à la
normale
alors là on est sur une nouvelle passe
finalement de notre plan blanc passer en
niveau 2 c'est à dire que le niveau 2 du
plan blanc nécessite de déprogrammer
toutes les interventions des pogrammes
abl donc globalement tous les
établissements ans reste la dimension de
leur plan blanc seules régions qu'elle
conserve aujourd'hui ça changera
probablement sur la deuxième place des
compliments qui voit le 22 juin prochain
mais au moment où je vous parle nous
avons effectivement déjà revu nos
pratiques puisque nous allons désormais
bâtiments élevés
tous les patients qui bloque tranchant
chez nous donc on va le réaliser une
besner à partir de début de la semaine
prochaine au moins 48 heures avant leur
admission pouvoir confirmer
effectivement qu'ils ne sont pas
porteurs estimant ducobu du décès nous
permettra d'être plus souple sur
effectivement que la prise en charge
dans le secteur
égalisation et au bloc opératoire mais
néanmoins on conserve un cri à l'encré
tous les visiteurs les accompagnants
avec un port du masque systématique
ainsi que les visiteurs et les patients
à se munir d'un masque des signes nous
parle mais systématiquement un masque
chirurgical
le lavage des mains est naturellement et
gentiment
systématique et puis le bien évidemment
les visites sont aujourd'hui encore
extrêmement régulé et les interventions
au bloc opératoire reste qu'elle
conditionnait sur les teams en cette
appréciation les chirurgiens de prendre
en charge le patient maintenant de
demain avec mes clips que j'avais plus
évoqués précédemment
l'un des plaisirs nous ne sommes pas
encore sur un fonctionnement normal ou
laid et jours et les semaines et les
petits mots qui s'annonce nous laissent
penser les couleurs
merci riscle d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien
berkshire je le rappelle vous êtes
directeur de l'hôpital privé de
versailles
[Musique]
c'était l'une des annonces phares de
l'acte 2 du déconfinement la réouverture
des terrasses des bars et restaurants
pour les départements en zone orange
dont fait partie les yvelines un moment
autant attendu par les restaurateurs que
les consommateurs si certains se tenait
prêt pour ouvrir dès le 2 juin d'autres
ont pris plus de temps a tout préparé
pour respecter les règles sanitaires
aurélie rezé patrick jacques de dixmude
les août interrogé le serveur ont
démasqué pour le servir les clients
avaient timmins et on va avoir les
masques à table entendu par contre
l'iran dans l'établissement limiteront
démasqué pour aller aux toilettes on va
éviter qu'ils viennent payer à la caisse
à table
ça permet effectivement que les clients
des pâtes aux attentes se déplacer et à
tous et d'énergie a trop on a laissé le
dernier week-end à notre personnel là
qui voit là comme chacun sait c'est
important de rattaquer avec des idées et
des défis zhixin on va s'étendre un peu
de chaque côté de notre établissement
est certainement utiliser les trois
places de parking devant devant notre
établissement c'était un rendez vous
important chaque été dans les yvelines
réunissant près de 3 millions de
personnes pendant deux mois
la fête des loges n'aura pas lieu à
cause de la crise sanitaire
le maire de la commune de saint germain
en laye a rendu sa décision en fin de
semaine dernière
un coup dur pour les forums inquiéter
reçu mardi après-midi en portage de
michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry c'est une première depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale la fête des
loges qui devait se dérouler du 26 juin
au 16 août n'aura pas lieu
le maire de la commune arnaud péricard
vient d'annoncer cette décision la
raison invoquée la crise sanitaire liée
aux copies de 19 ans le maire nous a
expliqué les problèmes c'était
sanitaires surtout qu' on est toujours
en zone orange et que
c'est compliqué pour organiser le flux
l'entrée des clients la distance entre
chaque client l'organisation d'un tel
événement dans la forêt de saint germain
les aurait également un impact
économique important pour la commune
le coût de l'organisation est supporté
par la commune la perte pourrait
atteindre 700 mille euros cette année en
raison d'un format réduit sur la durée
comme sur le nombre de forains présents
de leur côté les fora accuse le coup
déjà frappé par l'annulation de la foire
du trône les propriétaires l'attraction
et les restaurateurs craignent la
banqueroute avec le report de cette 360
huitième édition
la plupart la part de revenus on n'a
rien du tout pas son la lettre de l'état
mais elle a beaucoup qui ne touche pas
c'est compliqué il faut faire des
demandes des taux et puis il ya les plus
gros fonds a qui vont au negro crédit
ils vont déposer le bilan
on sait pas comment ça va faire l'avenir
les organisateurs espèrent un retour à
la normale en 2021 chaque année la fête
des loges accueille près de 3 millions
de visiteurs et 200 attractions
mardi 18 heures signé la fin des dépôts
de listes pour les candidats ayant accès
au second tour des élections municipales
tour d'horizon à saint quentin en
yvelines où sept communes sont
concernées par ce second tour aurait
lieu à l'issue du premier tour aux
clayes-sous-bois quatre candidats
étaient susceptibles de se maintenir
pour le second tour
finalement stéphanie jamin se retirer ce
sera une triangulaire avec une seule
liste de gauche celle de nicolas u qui
sera opposé à philipp guiguen et
anne-claire frémont sur la liste de
cette dernière figure la maire sortante
véronique côté millard qui entre-temps a
préféré soutenir son premier adjoint
philippe week-end à guyancourt quatre
candidats étaient en ballotage à l'issue
du premier tour
pour ce second tour la liste d'olivier
paréja fusionne avec celle du maire
sortant françois morton l'aiguillon
courtois auront donc le choix entre
trois listes françois morton rodolphe
baril et grégory pape
pas de surprise à plaisir les trois
listes arrivées en tête lors du premier
tour se maintiennent pour le scrutin du
28 juin la liste de la maire sortante
joséphine coleman berger sera opposée
aux listes de patrick jean terre et
annie joël prio et sni pour ce second
tour il n'y aura pas d'alliance attrape
ce sera une triangulaire avec la liste
du maire sortant guy malandain celle de
son ancien adjoint à lire à b enfin la
liste du conseiller municipal
d'opposition othman nasri ouf à la
verrière sur les quatre listes du
premier tour trois sont en lice pour le
28 juin prochain
celle de la maire sortante nelly duthu
la liste de son premier adjoint jean
yves blé et celle du conseiller
municipal d'opposition nicolas dainville
surprise en revanche à villepreux avec
une fusion de listes celle de valérie
ban arrivé en seconde position lors du
premier tour et celle de sylvie sva
ont-elles arrivé quatrième
il y aura donc une triangulaire à
villepreux avec le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau valérie bain et jean
baptiste à monique 3 c'est également le
nombre de listes pour le second tour à
voisins le bretonneux des listes
identique à celle du 15 mars dernier
celle de la maire sortante
alexandra rosetti celle d'olivier à
france ô et de béatrice pierrât
et ce sont en tout 45 communes des
yvelines où les électeurs devront
retourner aux urnes le 28 juin prochain
à mantes-la-ville pas de quadrangulaires
pour le second tour mais un duel à deux
dès le lendemain du premier tour romain
carbone avait fait savoir qu'il se
retirait la candidate de la gauche
hamiti smaghi s'est également retiré de
la course il ya deux jours
conséquence pour le scrutin du 28 juin
le maire sortant rassemblement national
cyril note fera face à la liste d'yves
et ressentent de samy dame hergé un duel
d'ailleurs dans lequel s'est immiscé
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental élus du canton de menthe
appelle à voter pour sam hill d'énergie
dans un communiqué pour mettre fin je
cite à la paralysie l' isolement et à
l'égarement de la commune aux mureaux ce
sera une triangulaire entre les trois
candidats arrivés en tête lors du
premier tour le maire sortant françois
garer sera face au candidat divers
droite hervé riou et à la candidat
divers gauche
agnès étendard enfin rambouillet
triangulaire également la candidate
divers droite véronique matillon arrivé
en tête le 15 mars dernier sera opposé à
la liste écologiste de david jutier et à
la liste lrm de gilles schmitt mercredi
brune poirson était à maurepas
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire s'est rendu dans la
déchetterie de la ville discussion
autour du fonctionnement du site et des
méthodes d'adaptation face à la crise
sanitaire gestes-barrières et
distanciation physique depuis le 4 mai
les sept déchetteries de saint quentin
en yvelines sont ouvertes
un accès se fait sur place uniquement
sur rendez-vous les propos sont
recueillis par patrick châteaux dixmude
et nicolas landry quand on le voit et
surtout quand on voit ya à peine
quelques semaines il y avait en gros 30
% des déchetteries seulement au plus
haut pic de la crise qui était ouverte
et bien là au contraire sans même
attendre la fin du décompte finement et
bien cette déchetterie a montré tous les
acteurs
ensemble s'ils sont mis main dans la
main pour dans le respect des règles
sanitaires pouvoir rouvrir et offrir ce
service essentiel non seulement
l'environnement mais aussi à l'ensemble
des citoyens
jeudi les collégiens ont repris le
chemin de l'école le collège de magellan
située à chanteloup les vignes est resté
ouvert pendant le confinement il
accueillait les enfants du personnel
soignant pendant la crise sanitaire
jeudi matin c'était la rentrée des
élèves de 6e en différé par groupes de
dix enfants
même par aldo étaient sur place c'est
une rentrée particulière pour les élèves
du collège magellan à chanteloup les
vignes dès leur arrivée désinfection des
mains et port du masque obligatoire 38
élèves de 6e font leur retour dans cet
établissement d'une capacité totale de 2
199 élèves distance d'un mètre
séparation des tables à la cantine
affiche tout le protocole sanitaire a
été mise en place
le ménage est également accentuée dans
ce collège qui accueillait les enfants
du personnel soignant pendant le
confinement
on ne fonctionne plus comme avant les
enfants n'ont plus de carnet de liaison
ça veut dire qu'il ya plus de punitions
il ya plus d'heures de retenue donc je
vous dis c'est une vraie un vrai rapport
de confiance d'accueil on essaie aussi
de s'adapter davantage aux élèves dans
les classes
onze élèves maximum sauf dans les salles
de sciences avec 15 élèves certains
professeurs continuent le suivi des
élèves à distance mais la plupart des
enseignants sont de retour il met en
place des projets pédagogiques avec
leurs élèves
la fresque qu'ils veulent perdre dans la
cour ou qu'il s'agisse pour vivre va
raconter cette histoire de déconfinement
de faire une chanson avec une artiste
elle les enfants pensent aussi aux
vacances dans ce contexte particulier la
ville proposera des activités
c'est un principe il n'y a pas une
journée on ne propose pas quelque chose
à un groupe de groupe trois groupes
utiliser l'ensemble du territoire et
tout ce qu'il a comme mme équipements
publics en équipements d'extérieur
troisièmement travailler sur toutes les
tranches d'âge faire de l'éducatif du
culturel du sportif tout mélanger et
faire autant que peu se peut et sait ce
que j'étais en train de valider du de la
mise à distance aussi certain nombre de
possibilités à l'extérieur 41 % des
élèves ont déclaré revenir au collège
magellan à partir de lundi et pour ceux
qui restent encore confiné et
continueront de suivre les cours à la
maison
cette situation d'élèves loin de l'école
depuis mi mars inédite a provoqué
plusieurs inégalités
de nombreuses familles n'ont pas pu
assurer la continuité pédagogique par
manque de moyens technologiques pour
remédier à cela l'association le rocher
oasis des cités aux mureaux s'est occupé
d'équipé des familles en matériel
informatique propos recueillis par
aurélie rond l'idée c'était de voilà on
a on a fait un une sorte de recensement
on va dire des différentes familles avec
lesquelles le rocher en lien et il nous
a semblé pertinent de fournir ces
ordinateurs la aux familles qui a eu des
soucis ou là dans laquelle il y avait
plusieurs enfants à faire travailler des
familles avec lesquelles
on avait aussi un lien construit dans le
temps voilà c'est des enfants qui sont
accompagnés par le rocher depuis
plusieurs années maintenant des
collégiens parfois engagés contre le
harcèlement scolaire 11 projets ont été
primés jeudi lors d'une cérémonie
virtuel
le concours non au harcèlement a livré
son palmarès des 1020 il a pour but de
donner la parole aux jeunes sur ce
phénomène qui touche environ 700 mille
élèves en france pour participer il
suffisait de produire un support de leur
choix sur le sujet et parmi les
lauréates de nombreuses yvelinois on
retrouve notamment les affiches des
collégiens de guillaume apollinaire à
plaisir et de sainte-thérèse à
rambouillet le prix cyber harcèlement
revient au collège charles péguy du
chesnay rocancourt le prix spécial
harcèlement sexuel et sexiste pour cette
vidéo des jeunes du collège des prés à
montigny le bretonneux
en ce qui concerne le prix des
élémentaires il a été attribué à l'école
des hirondelles à aulnay sur mauldre
enfin le coup de coeur académique a été
décerné aux lycéens d'evariste galois à
sartrouville
bravo à tous les participants et
lauréats vous pouvez retrouver leurs
oeuvres sur le site de l'académie de
versailles
enfin cette semaine pour notre rubrique
dans les archives de tv 78 auto sur le
passage du tour de france 2010 9 dans
les yvelines
la dernière étape s'est élancé de
rambouillet le 28 juillet avant le
triomphe du colombien et gagnent bernal
[Musique]
vitrine vélo maillot rambouillet et aux
couleurs de tour de france dimanche 28
juillet la grande boucle fait escale
dans la cité royale à l'occasion du
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
une première depuis juillet 2012
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail
mais l'équipe aille sont naturellement
et puis un une centaine bonne centaine
de bénévoles
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée à
oublier tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs nationaux
le rendez vous a attiré plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs sur
cette journée l'occasion pour ces
aficionados du vélo d'approcher les
coureurs qui les ont fait vibrer cette
année on habite en région centre
on a pas d'étape à côté de chez nous
d'accord donc on est obligé de faire
deux heures de route pour venir les voir
j'espère rencontrer beaucoup de coureurs
que j'aime bien que je voudrais d'avoir
devant - parce que à la tsfc bien
d'ivoire biais des vents de 100 par
mieux celui que tout le monde veut voir
c'est lui et gagnent pernal à 22 ans le
coureur colombien est presque assuré de
remporter le tour de france avant le
départ à rambouillet il doit juste
terminer l'étape
un résultat qui enthousiasme les
milliers de supporteurs colombien
présent dans les yvelines
[Applaudissements]
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grand jour de ma vie c'est une joie
très grande c'est la première fois qu'un
sportif colombien remporte le tour de
france c'est quelque chose de très
important et nous sommes fiers de
représenter notre drapeau et notre pays
une fois les signatures et laissez-les
fit terminer direction la ligne de
départ pour les spectateurs pour voir le
départ de la caravane et de ses 160
véhicules décorés aux couleurs des
marques
les coureurs s'élancent ensuite à 18h10
depuis le parc du château de rambouillet
et en direction de paris
les yvelinois reverront le tour de
france l'année prochaine une convention
a été signée par le département pour
accueillir la dernière étape de la
grande boucle jusqu'en 2023
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'être fidèle aux 7,8 l'hebdo retour de
l'actualité locale bel un deal avec le
7-8 journal du week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or m
[Musique]